[Music]
[Applause]
tom e curran covers the patriots uh he's
a frequent guest on the program patriots
insider for nbc sports in boston i saw
on social media where tom was going into
dunkin donuts and he locked his car
the car was running
and he had a dog in in the car went in
to get his coffee
and came out didn't realize that he had
locked the doors
and his spare keys i think were in the
car
so
everybody's looking at him like you you
lock yourself out of your car there's a
dog in there
tom
you
you don't have your spare keys in the
car
and you don't have your spare set of
keys in the car
as well
yes
that if your house just a mile away
needs to be beckoned
they can bring you the spare set
when did you know you were in trouble
when
you uh
locked locked the keys in and the dog
was in the car
when i went to open the door oh and it
well i think i might have seen that the
button was down a little bit oh boy and
then you just clicked okay keys in car
car running
and dog just sitting there like this
[Laughter]
wait you you can't have the car running
in the first place
you live in the mean streets of
connecticut i know
but are you worried somebody is is going
to break into your car and no
i mean it's the dunk of donuts it's not
it wasn't far it's like right i was
parked against the window i don't know
i'm just i don't know how hard it is to
press the button and turn it off and
then press the button to turn it back on
oh and and that feeling when you're
looking inside you got your coffee and
your dog is going hey come on let's go
and uh everybody's looking at you
yeah yeah and then and then when the key
guy comes because you know
those guys are constantly experiencing
the morons of life
and
you're gonna have a spare set no it's in
there
okay keep your head up uh
how did you think this game was going to
play out
i thought it was going to be a
convincing buffalo win dan they're a
better team
i think that
certainly in the second matchup if you
remember tim graham from the athletic
and a few other reporters
quoted josh allen leaving the field at
gillette stadium saying who the fudge
did they think i was
meaning they didn't take him seriously
enough and they haven't really taken him
seriously enough and i think the bills
had that edge to them where look the
patriots have lost three out of four
they're not as good as us what are we
doing here we're going to steamroll
these guys so i said had 27
to 13.
was this a good year for the patriots
it was a good year it was a good year
because they found some things
especially the quarterback position
um
they got some improvement from some key
players but it was a horrendously
disappointing finish
i mean they ascended to the number one
seed remember we i wrote a hey why not
us call them maybe the patriots and the
bucks will meet in the super bowl
um why not them because they're not
really that great you know the only
teams that they beat were either
completely diminished by injury
tennessee
um
for example or
over match the jets i mean they
outscored the jets
um
jaguars
and
they put up 45 in the browns
by like
136 to
20.
so that's a lot of what inflated those
numbers where people are saying patriots
have one of the best offenses in the nfl
no they don't they just track me against
bad teams
you think you have your quarterback
they have a quarterback dan they have a
quarterback
i don't know if he's the quarterback but
he will be the quarterback for five
years certainly
um and they're gonna have to figure a
way to build around him i think that's
what's interesting about this you watch
you know mahomes or josh allen or
to throw in aaron rodgers you know as a
mobile guy or lebar jackson or justin
herbert
they bring that dimension to it you know
herbert's not only
fast but he's got a weapon same thing as
allen mack jones isn't very mobile and
he's challenged in terms of arm strength
compared to the rest of the league so
you better put some players around him
and have a defense that's not going to
let up a touchdown
every single drive
to the main competition in your division
so it's not going to be as much in my
estimation than about matt jones as it's
going to be about how well do the
patriots finally figure out how to draft
at the receiver position
i like him i don't love mac jones
because i think the the ceiling for him
is limited he can be he can be good but
it's almost got to be a system that
makes him better than what he really is
because
that's throwing people open
um
i don't know if he had you know maybe he
uh
has that internal clock that brady had
and you know what you're doing when
you're supposed to like all of those
intangibles i'd still like to have some
tangibles with my quarterback here and i
don't know how many tangibles i have
with mack jones
yeah it's kind of a deadly combination
if you're not mobile
and your arm's not that
strong that's
going to ask a lot of your brain it's
going to ask a lot of your aptitude it's
going to ask a lot of your accuracy
fortunately he checks those boxes
but
he has to improve his arm strength i
mean you can see it it's palpable yeah
you know when someone throws to the
outside
you know on the downfield florida ago
where i i didn't hate it the one that
got picked by micah hyde but people
weren't wrong when saying
if it was three feet further out in
front of him
then it's either his catch ago
or nobodies
we're talking to uh tom kearn looks like
you're an extra in the departed um
tough guy yeah yeah i know it's coming
at that time of year though i mean once
the season ends all bets are off
the patriots insider for uh nbc sports
boston
um we just assume that belichick is
going to continue to coach right
he said that that is what he expects to
do yesterday on his season-ending
conference call so yeah he'll be back
and he turns 70 in a couple of months
turns 70 in april okay i mean the
patriots it's interesting because
you know the patriots over the last
three years
have in 2019 the last year brady got
whisked out at home by the tennessee
titans in the playoffs
didn't make the playoffs with cam newton
at quarterback no real plan in place for
the quarterback position
then they went on you know a record
spending spree
this offseason they found a quarterback
they found a running back in the draft
in stevenson and a good defensive
lineman in barmore
but in the end their free agent
acquisitions judon was good for three
quarters of the year kendrick bourne was
good all year ago wasn't good
john smith was non-existent and hunter
henry was good there's a few other guys
they picked up too jalen mills but
in the final analysis it wasn't
an a shopping spree by bill it was
probably a b or a b minus
but the team's been renovated a bit but
you still look at it and say
it's three years of declining returns do
you
is there a point at which robert kraft
says you know what
i don't know who my defensive
coordinator is we can't stop the best
team in the division
i wonder if robert craft ever
scrutinizes the option of maybe maybe we
need a reboot too
handicap the afc playoff picture now if
i gave you buffalo or the field
i would take uh the field
because i think the kansas city
defensively can really be
swarming and again i mean
ben roethlisberger couldn't throw it
you know
to the water from the end of the dock at
this juncture however
i think if you look at
what kansas city has done in so many big
games i think they can they can run with
a lot of teams defensively
and certainly the way they exploded
against a good pittsburgh defense the
patriots aren't a good defense so don't
don't don't get it twisted
on what you saw saturday night
it's always great to talk to you tom
this was a nice visit this was really
buttoned down good start to the week i
hope everybody enjoys it well you get to
still root for your boyfriend tom in the
plans so everything's okay i know
i know
yep tommy actually oh tom tom
tommy you're gonna buy some of those uh
brady uh sweatshirts that he's selling
i got it on sale i got the t-shirt for
45. i like it hot
very hot
prices thank you tom did you see the
prices yes i do yes i did eye popping
but you know what happens sometimes you
just raise the price
because then it makes it seem like oh my
god
i gotta have that like
of course i want a you know a 200
sweatshirt that just says brady across
it
that happens to you
yeah well not me but i still think
belichick needs to have a clothing line
where it's ripped you know like they
have distressed looks
he has distress written all over him and
then and then maybe you have like a 25
sweatshirt like like he goes low end
to try to cut out
dan this has been my idea for him it's
pre-cameo i've had this idea for 15
years it's called bellagrams he just
leaves voicemails for people
hey it's bill
how you doing happy birthday
the people would pay 30 000 for that
telegrams
mark it down
thanks tom
see you bud
bye buddy have a great week
tom kern
yeah i don't know if you would pay a lot
for you know a bill belichick message
there i think the bill belichick
clothing line you know people buy
distressed furniture all the time jeans
distressed jeans like imagine i remember
growing up i couldn't get another pair
of jeans i had to wear the ones i had
and they had holes all over them